the ability to read people matters in
every aspect of your life
but today specifically i'm going to talk
about business and here's why
if you're somebody that has plans of one
day being an executive right
if you have plans of one day being a ceo
and
you know a president a founder somebody
that's running a company and people are
working with you
you have to know how to read people and
these are a couple things you need to
know about reading people you need to be
able to read a room
you're sitting in a room is that guy on
my side is this guy on my side
is she on my side is the attorney on my
side who's not on my side
who is somebody that can be is
reasonable that can have a proper
negotiation with
and who is absolutely not reasonable and
who doesn't have information right now
let me give them a break
and maybe we they can find out that my
proposal i'm making is going to be good
thing
let me go step up past this when it
comes down to reading people
so many times i'll see folks who want to
be executives they want to be leaders
but unfortunately behind closed doors
they are fiends of compliments and what
do i mean by this
they love having people say you look so
amazing today
you're wonderful you're better than
johnny you're better than bobby
i tell you you're doing a great job the
other guy that was here he wasn't as
good as you
oh let me tell you that person right
there 10 times you are 10 times better
than them
i love your style all of these things
are like i need to hear this so often
and the need to constantly be
complimented is a character issue
how do i know this years ago i'm 25
26 i constantly needed to be told
that i'm doing a great job why here's
what happened
i wasn't confident whether i know how to
do the job or not i second-guess myself
constantly
i don't know if i can pull this off or
down i don't know if this is for me or
not
so i said oh you're so amazing okay good
oh my god i'm gonna stay motivated one
more thing oh so you're so great you saw
this
what i didn't realize that i hadn't
learned the difference between
compliment and flattery
what is the difference between
complement and flattery compliment is
coming from somebody that's sincere
and has no motives behind it they just
want to tell you you did a great job
flattery comes with a motive because
flattery is a method of softening you
softening you up to to win you over and
you know kind of get you on their side
and gradually
extending my motives over to you right
so let's talk about compliments
i was i was having a conversation with a
few guys here then i said let me tell
you guys this much
my list of people whose compliments
matter to me is such a short list that i
can count them on two hands
so very short list it isn't hundreds of
people it's maybe 10 or 15 people
that if they compliment me has a lot of
value in my life
a lot of value in my life so if i get a
call from a competitor
or if i get a call from an enemy and the
call starts this way
let me tell you man you're so amazing
you're the best of the best
you're wonderful i've never seen
anything like you i just sit there and
i'm
literally not listening to anything
they're saying to me because i trust my
enemies a lot
i have a lot of trust in my enemies in
my list of top 10 people i trust the
most
guess who's at the top of my list my
enemies now you may say pat what do you
mean
you trust them more than people that
work with you yes yes i do
i trust my enemies more than i trust the
people that i work with
how is that even possible isn't that an
insult absolutely not
tell me what you mean by you trust your
enemies more than the people that work
with you i'll explain it to you
here's what i mean i trust that my
enemies
hate the fact that i'm taking market
share away from them and they would do
anything
to take the market share back i trust
that my enemies
internally would like to see me go out
of business i trust
that my enemies would love to take my
best clients away from me
i trust that my enemies will gladly take
my best
salesperson from me why because that's
capitalism
i trust it it's called competition if
i'm taking market share away from you
you want it by the way in election biden
and trump
you don't think biden will gladly take
another state from trump you don't think
trump will take a stake no
another state from biden they'll gladly
take it trump trusts
every morning he wakes up democrats will
do anything for him to not get elected
and biden and democrats wake up every
morning knowing trump and the
republicans will do anything they can to
take it away from the democrats
it's a very high trust factor and you
got to have that as well so you cannot
be naive so let me go back
to how this whole thing got started
which is what reading
people reading rooms reading
motive why are you complimenting me why
are you flattering me
why are you telling me such amazing
things about me what do you need from me
next by the way kids do these to parents
all the time
kids do this to parents all the time dad
let me tell you what's that
you know i told people in school today
you're the greatest dad in the world oh
really
yeah you're the greatest dad in the
world now what kid
100 believes that's the greatest dad in
the world
you know kids typically remember what
parents did wrong right
that you're the best greatest dad in the
world really awesome
thanks buddy now you wait one minute
five minutes
ten minutes yeah daddy hey dad can we go
buy that video game that just came out
it's only a hundred dollars
see how that works out it's everywhere
now this doesn't mean your kids are
bad people you just have to understand
what's the motive
what is the motive flattery and in
business more than in personal life
you have to watch out for it in a big
way and when it comes down to
compliments
the last exercise i want you to do is
the following thing here i want you to
get a list of names of people
in your life where their compliments
matter to you the most
and then ask yourself how much do you
think compliments from everybody
are you constantly seeking compliments
so think about the person you don't like
think about the person that you're so
furious with is it because they haven't
complimented you in a long time
why do you need it so bad why do you
need it so bad why must you get a
compliment from that person
if you desperately need a compliment
from that person
guess who owns you that person if they
give it to you
great if they don't give it to you
you're still free because your list of
compliments is that short list of 5 10
15 20 names
that matter the most meaning well my
kids are 32 years old
and we're sitting one there they're
making their own money they have their
own family and they say daddy let me
tell you something man
i gotta tell you this what's up buddy
thank you for raising me the way you did
you were tough on me man but but thank
you for that ah very cool
you got it buddy daddy loves you when i
sit with an executive or somebody i'm
doing a business with and we're sitting
there saying
hey you know we just made 48 million
dollars investing into your company
i just want you know man you're the best
investment we ever made
and there's no other motives behind it
because the check's already been cut
that compliment matters when you work
with executives in the company and they
say
you know that one time we were going
through that one situation yeah i wasn't
fully supportive about the decision
we're getting ready to make
but 15 years later i'mma tell you this
i'm so glad you had the guts to make
that decision
thank you those are the compliments you
ought to be looking for
not the compliments from people that use
it as a form of flattery
to get inside your head and be able to
get what they want out of you
so again a few lists you got to make
number one top ten people you trust the
most in business
number two who are the people's
compliment that matter to you the most
and number three eliminate many names
whose compliments shouldn't matter to
you and you will be amazed
how much more freer you'll be to be able
to read people
in every business situation that you'll
be in